"Applaudissements"
Alors, vous n'avez pas pu rater ça. Ces dernières semaines tout le monde en parle
Vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo je ne parle pas de Caroline et Safia
mais bien de cette fuite de données dingue
et si j'avais une production vous auriez eu le droit à une série d'images
dans tous les sens de JT du monde entier avec plein de journalistes
qui font Panama Papers (avec différents accents)
Mais comme je n'en ai pas, et bien on se contentera de l'incroyable effet que je viens de faire, voila.
Les Panama Papers c'est juste la plus grosse fuite d'informations journalistiques de ces dernières années.
On parle de 2600 gigaoctets de données dans 11,5 millions de fichiers.
2600 gigaoctets ! Cyrusly ?! C'est énorme !
Et ces données elles sont importantes puisqu'elles mettent en lumière
Des liens obscurs entre le monde de la finance et les paradis fiscaux
Le tout en provenance directe de Mossack Fonseca
cabinet panaméen spécialiste dans la domiciliation de sociétés offshore
Alors je vais vous expliquer un peu mieux ça mais à titre de comparaison
Sur les 5 dernières fuites du même genre. 4 faisaient moins de 5 gigas on n'est donc
clairement pas sur des révélations de la
même ampleur
et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on en parle
autant.
Et d'ailleurs si ça ne se fait que
maintenant c'est peut-être parce qu'ils
ont une mauvaise connexion, tout simplement,
le truc fait quand même
1300 WeTransfer, précisons le.
Quoi qu'il en soit c'est important,
C'est important que ça soit arrivé à nos oreilles
et c'est grâce au travail acharné de
109 rédactions réparties dans 76 pays.
Je te laisse imaginer la gueule du Google Doc
ensemble elles ont révélé le
fonctionnement d'un système créé par
et pour l'opacité de ses
bénéficiaires. Bénéficiaires
allant de parfaits inconnus à des
figures de premier plan
issus d'univers politique, économique
sportif et culturel.
Alors, ok je peux comprendre que ça puisse faire
beaucoup d'informations d'un coup.
On a été saturé de données par les
médias, et on ne sait pas forcément quoi retenir.
Heureusement pour vous,
vous avez sonné à la bonne porte. P'tit récap,
Tout d'abord le Panama sur une carte ça se place ici.
Faites pas genre que tout le monde le
savait ! Je suis sûr il y en a un ou deux qui ne savaient pas.
Bref, dans ce Panama il y a un cabinet qui s'appelle Mossack Fonseca. Et on va voir
comment ils ont organisé toute cette fraude,
et je vais reprendre l'excellente métaphore développée par Vox.
Alors , partons du principe que vous conservez
vos économies dans une
belle tirelire cochon
posée sur l'étagère de votre chambre
votre problème c'est que votre mère elle  n'arrête pas de regarder dans votre
tirelire, pour pouvoir s'assurer de
ce qui y rentre
et ce qui en sort.
Et vous, vous n'aimez pas trop ça. Parce que si elle sait que vous êtes
pété de thunes,
elle va vous demander de participer aux
frais la maison, par exemple.
Donc ce que vous faites c'est que vous
gardez votre tirelire cochon dans votre
chambre.
Mais vous en achetez une seconde,
que vous allez entreposer
chez votre voisin.
Parce que votre voisin Michel, sa mère
elle est cool et elle regarde pas dans les
tirelires qui se trouvent chez elle.
Du coup, ça vous permet de faire rentrer et
sortir de l'argent de votre seconde tirelire
sans attirer l'attention votre mère.
mais peut-être que la mère de Michel
elle ne fait pas ça parce qu'elle est cool
mais parce qu'elle a proposé à
tous les enfants du quartier de garder
en sécurité leur seconde tirelire,
contre une petite somme d'argent.
Vous avez compris l'idée,
c'est comme ça que fonctionnent les
paradis fiscaux, comme le Panama ou les
Îles Caïmans.
Et proposent une fiscalité très
intéressante
sont très peu regardant de la
provenance, la destination des sommes
d'argent. Et offrent de réelles facilitées
pour y créer des sociétés sans en
révéler les propriétaires.
et c'est cette opacité qui intéresse
tout le monde peut écrire un faux nom
sur la tirelire cochon
qu'il a caché chez la mère de Michel
En fait la mère de Michel, c'est Mossack Fonseca.
à travers ces 40 bureaux disséminés
dans une douzaine de pays
elle facilite la création de ces tirelires un peu spéciales qui sont les
sociétés offshore
dans les paradis fiscaux. Les sociétés offshore c'est une grosse coquille vide,
une sorte de vaisseau vaisseau fantôme
qui ne réalise aucun business dans le
territoire où elles sont implantées
mais qui se contente de lui se déclarer
propriétaire de vos actifs et vous
permettent du coup
de bénéficier d'une meilleure fiscalité
sauf qu'en fait il y a différents
degrés d'opacité et de brouillage de piste
La création d'une simple société offshore,
c'est un peu le happy meal
de l'optimisation fiscale. Et ce n'est
pas toujours suffisant pour s'assurer
une opacité optimale
puisque vous apparaissez toujours parmi
les membres du conseil d'administration
de l'entreprise
donc si quelqu'un vous cherche vraiment, ben il vous retrouve
donc du coup Mossack Fonseca il
propose un truc encore mieux, son menu
best of, avec l'attribution de faux administrateurs qui se chargeront de toute
votre paperasse,  vos signatures
mais aussi de faux actionnaires qui
apparaîtront à votre place sur des
documents qui pourraient être
compromettants
et ensuite pour le maxi best avec la sauce creamy deluxe
on vous propose de renforcer l'opacité
en multipliant les sociétés off shore
de deux façons
la première façon en mode boîte nugget, c'est à dire en divisant vos
actifs entre vos sociétés.
La seconde façon : poupées
russes, en les impliquant les unes dans
les autres, histoire que l'unique
actionnaire
d'une de vos sociétés soit une autre
société,
qui soit elle même détenue
par une troisième
chacune situées dans un paradis fiscal
différent avec ses propres règles
et atypismes
Autant vous dire que la fuite des
données a dû sauver pas mal de
nuits blanches du côté de l'administration fiscale
parce que c'est tout un système qui a
été mis en lumière par ces
révélations. Sauf que
c'est pas parce que vous montez une
société off-shore que vous êtes dans
l'illégalité
en fait certains recours par exemple à sa société
pour faciliter leur développement à
l'international
utilisant l'opacité de ce système pour
préserver leur stratégie
ou camoufler leur identité
réelle jusqu'au bon déroulement de
l'opération
un peu comme Mathieu B.
il voulait créer son entreprise et
s'installer en Asie, il a donc créé une
société aux îles vierges britanniques
via la branche de Mossack Fonseca à
Singapour
car le fait d'avoir déjà une société
pouvait accélérer son processus
d'installation
alors on a voulu en savoir plus sur
Mathieu B., du coup on a investigué
afin de savoir quel type de personne
c'était.
Et on est tombé sur une interview de
lui dans son club de hand
où à la question
"une chose que tu fais avant un match", il
nous répond : "faire mes lacets"
donc ça a l'air d'être un garçon
parfaitement normal
et pour cause
en fait c'est complètement légal pour un particulier de placer de l'argent à
l'étranger dans une société off-shore
sans le déclarer mais seulement s'il ya
ces trois critères :
Ne pas être assujetti à l'impôt sur
la fortune, ne pas percevoir de
dividendes de cette société
et ne pas avoir lui-même de comptes
étrangers liés à cette société.
donc techniquement c'est possible
mais comme le précise Christophe Moreau
avocat fiscaliste
créer une société off-shore et
déclarer tous les revenus
qu'on y loge, ça n'a
aucun intérêt.
L'intérêt de création de telles
sociétés,
c'est qu'elles effacent le nom leurs
propriétaires réels
et leur permettent donc par exemple
d'échapper à l'impôt,
d'exonérer leur descendance de droits
de succession,
de blanchir de l'argent au de camoufler
des actifs à des créanciers.
Alors ça à l'air fou comme ça,
mais ça peut être les gens qui cachent
leur argent avant le divorce par exemple
donc ça c'est illégal.
Et le truc c'est que créé une société
off-shore pour ne pas profiter de
l'avantage offert par l'opacité,
c'est complètement absurde. C'est comme si on achetait un citron, du sel, de la
tequila,
qu'on parte en soirée et que tu me dises que t'as pas prévu de faire un tequila paf
Me prend pas pour un con mon gars !
Alors du coup c'est pour ça que
Yves Thréard, le patron du Figaro,
"M. Platini, mais M.Platini il a un fond,
pourquoi il aurait pas un fond si cet
argent est déclaré ? - Vous voulez dire
général des gens ?" - On mélange tout !"
C'est vrai que tout est mélangé ,  il n'a pas tort la dessus.
"On mélange tout,
on met tout en pâture y en a marre de
cette société !
Demain on va faire quoi ? le listing des gens qui ont le Sida ?
C'est quoi le rapport ?
ça n'a absolument aucun sens !
d'ailleurs ça en a tellement peu qu'il s'est excusé sur Twitter
"Je regrette la comparaison entre les évadés fiscaux et les malades du sida."
"Bien sûr que qu'évasion fiscale et sida n'ont rien à voir, mais je n'aime pas les
listings et la dictature de la délation,
ça ne vous rappelle rien ?
alors non seulement le mec passe une
comparaison avec le sida à une comparaison
avec la shoah
mais en plus il a horreur de la délation
mais attend mec, divulguer ce genre
d'informations quand on est le patron du
Figaro ?
C'est juste ton taf !
C'est pour ça qu'une fuite comme les
Panama Papers a une importance
capitale
on peut pas compter sur genre de
personnes pour mettre un coup de pied
dans la fourmilière de temps en temps, du coup,
à force de faire pression sur les
paradis fiscaux, scandale après scandale,
on peut espérer qu'ils abandonnent les
services de dissimulation
que leurs clients affectionnent tant.
Mais justement, on a parlé un peu mieux du système ex cetera.. Maintenant, parlons d'eux :
les clients.
Pour voir qui ça touche.
Alors, parmi les noms révélés par les
Panama Papers, on retrouve
12 chefs d'Etat
ou de gouvernement
dont 6 encore en activit.... Ah non pardon, 5.
On vient de m'annoncer que le Premier Ministre islandais a démissionné.
Ah en même temps, t'as 7% de la population de l'Islande
qui a manifesté pour qu'il se barre
les mecs étaient hyper motivés.
Les gars ils y allaient avec des bananes
et ils balançaient des petits suisses, vraiment.
Il y a aussi le 29 des 500 plus
grandes fortunes du monde et 128
dirigeants politiques et hauts
fonctionnaires,
et évidemment il y a Cahuzac et Balkany qui y sont... Beh
c'est décevant pour le coup quoi !
bah ils sont toujours là où on les
attend !
Enfin je sais pas, surprenez nous putain ! 'Fin faîtes quelque chose quoi !
alors on serait tenté de dire " foutus super riches,
toujours les mêmes les politiques c'est
vraiment tous des pourris" Mais pas
si vite mon coco,
sur les millions de ressortissants
français retrouvés dans les documents
95% sont des citoyens lambda aux profils
et aux motivations bien plus diverses que
l'on pourrait imaginer
Alors c'est des chefs d'entreprise avec une
forte prédominance des secteurs de
commerce de gros et des textiles,
c'est des avocats, des médecins,
Mais aussi des commerçants comme
des bouchers ou des coiffeurs, pensez-y
la prochaine fois que vous irez vous
couper les cheveux
*chuchotte* "ça peut être n'importe qui..."
alors qui ça pénalise cette histoire ?
eh ben ça pénalise l'Etat
vu que c'est des gens qui ne paient pas
d'impôts sur ce qu'ils devraient.
donc la question qui se pose c'est : qu'est ce que l'Etat fait contre ça ?
eh bien le problème c'est que François
Hollande qui s'était montré
assez offensif vis-à-vis de  l'évasion
fiscale il a des résultats qui restent
contrastés. Certes les moyens de lutte
contre la délinquance fiscale ont
augmenté suite à l'affaire Cahuzac
avec un accroissement des effectifs de
lutte
contre les fraudes fiscales ou des résaux de blanchiment
et l'adoption d'un texte de loi
permettant le durcissement de la
législation
mais la promesse de campagne d'interdire aux banques la possibilité d'exercer
dans les paradis fiscaux, elle a été
rapidement remplacée
dans une loi votée en 2013 par un
devoir de transparence des banques quant
à leurs activités
dans les territoires dits non
coopératifs;
Un devoir de transparence
qui montre clairement son insuffisance
justement dans le cas des Panama Papers,
puisque le Panama avait été sorti,
par Nicolas Sarkozy, de la liste noire
des paradis fiscaux en 2011,
et parce que la définition même de
paradis fiscal étant relativement
restreinte, il est assez facile
pour les banques de prétexter n'y avoir
pas aucune activité.
C'est le cas de la Société Générale par
exemple et ce tweet de Kerviel était
juste magique
"je souhaite une bien belle semaine à la
société générale ainsi qu'à ses
conseils" #Panamapapers #PanamaLeaks
Effectivement elle avait fermé ses implantations au Panama sans pour autant stopper les
relations commerciales avec Mossack Fonseca qui lui aura permis d'ouvrir
un millier de sociétés offshore pour ses clients.
La solution serait donc peut-être
celle de l'échange automatique des
données entre différents pays, promis
par Hollande en 2013
Alors même si la mesure est complexe
elle sera indispensable pour qui veut
supprimer l'opacité
toujours présente
dans les structures offshore et
accentuer la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale
et franchement c'est largement
réalisable.
Fin 2015, c'était 74 pays qui avaient
confirmé par écrit
leur volonté de procéder à ces
échanges informations
dont le Panama. *raclements de gorge*
et les accords doivent entrer en
vigueur en 2018
ce qui aurait pu être suffisant pour
nettoyer ce qu'il y avait à nettoyer.
donc les volontés, elles semblent évoluer dans
le bon sens et c'est une bonne chose
la France, elle a par exemple récupéré 2,6 milliards
en 2015 grâce à la régularisation des
dossiers de personnes détenant un
compte bancaire
non déclaré à l'étranger.
C'est énorme, et aujourd'hui ils
sont submergés de demandes de
régularisation parce que l'affaire a
fait peur à tout le monde et c'est cool
Les volontés évoluent dans le bon sens
oui et non, ainsi ce que j'aurais aimé
vous dire mais depuis vendredi 15 avril
et le vote de la "directive Secrets d'Affaires"
c'est un peu plus difficile.
Pour vous expliquer un peu les choses,
le parlement européen a voté un texte
qui est un peu comme le Secret d'Etat mais pour les entreprises. L'idée c'est de les
protéger de la concurrence déloyale
et ce genre de trucs.
Sauf que c'est un texte qui peut
rapidement dissuader les journalistes
d'investigations
ou les lanceurs d'alerte de faire leur taf
s'ils ne souhaitent pas croulés sous les
procès
Et on est pas sûr que l'affaire des Panama Papers aurait pu être
divulguée dans ses conditions.
Cela va donc demander encore plus de cran qu'avant
et c'est problématique.
mais quoi qu'il en soit, c'était
important qu'on en parle aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut se rendre compte
que l'évasion fiscale c'est le problème
numéro 1
du financement de nos économies
à l'heure où de nombreux pays de
l'union européenne se serrent la ceinture
l'évasion fiscale ça pourrait
représenter mille milliards de pertes
fiscales par an
rien qu'en France l'évasion fiscale
ça représenterait 60 à
80 milliards de pertes ce qui est très
éloigné des pauvres 2 à 4 milliards
perdus à cause de fraudes
aux prestations sociales dont on entend
pourtant parler de bien plus
et si vous avez du mal
à figurer ce qu'un chiffre pareil pourrait représenter, l'excellente ?
l'a fait pour vous :
si en france tout le monde jouait le jeu
de l'impôt,
des particuliers aux sociétés,
et bien on pourrait équilibrer les finances
publiques et distribuer aux ménages
80 % des sommes versées
au titre de l'impôt sur le revenu en
Donc allez-y, faites du business, enrichissez-vous,
créez de la valeur, faites le à fond, faites du profit !
Mais juste un truc.
Respectez la loi.
J'espère que cet épisode vous aura plu, pouce en l'air si c'est le cas,
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne
pas rater les prochains épisodes
d'ailleurs je balance bientôt un Coup de Phil',
parce que je les ai pas arrêtés les CDP, c'est juste que  je voulais tester
un autre truc
Un gros merci aux tippers pour soutenir le projet, si vous aussi vous voulez blanchir
votre argent, n'hésitez pas à cliquer sur le lien tipeee
n'hésitez pas aussi à me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
et partagez la vidéo si vous pensez
qu'elle est intéressante, love, peace.